um
outside of the drug conversation uh no
let's talk about some of the game
you know because i feel like you do have
the internet figured out you've had a
very successful uh
career uh in the public eye what are
some things you think that like
people are like with some misconceptions
about
kind of that that world that you came
from and like how like what would be
some advice you would give some upcoming
content creators because
you know people they want to cross over
or well no no i'm talking like just
getting into
like both of my sons like my son's a fan
of yours right um
but like both of my kids they want to
grow up and be youtubers
yeah and now i hate i know you hate that
term
and we'll get to that too what the y
word yeah the y word
yeah can't say that to round me but what
i'm saying is like you know you
you you figured that [ __ ] out you've
kind of you know
figured it out what would be some advice
you would give some kids watching right
now who's like yo
i want to do that that's what i want to
do when i when i get older
okay i mean it's really
like this might sound like cliche or
whatever but
it's literally just being consistent
like i'm talking about
2017 i was uploading every
day i'm talking about if you go if you
can if you can put
january first yeah december 31st
2017 it's gonna say at least 500 videos
wow i'm talking about eating
19. crazy then 2018
after that it's like i had residual
income oh
[ __ ] like i'm probably three videos a
day so 2018 i'm just
that was a breeze damn so it's really
just the consistency because
do you remember in 2017 before you
became that consistent like do you
remember
like the jump in um subscribers you had
uh yeah i mean i blew up after i
dropped out of college now i blew up i
got
i had an x back in the past and i did
like this little
cheating prank on her and it blew up and
then i started vlogging from there
that blew up and then i went back
sophomore year in college
and i was making so much cheese i just
dropped out and moved out here
and you was editing your own videos oh
my [ __ ] damn
i gotta edit it for a little bit but i
didn't like it because it made me more
lazy
so i mean it was days i upload seven
videos in one day
i ain't talking about like no reactions
i'm talking about seven
ten minute plus vlogs [ __ ] i'm talking
about not eating
jesus christ but i was making six
figures a month
like that [ __ ] going crazy